[Musique]
c'est au musée de villèle que série
melchior président du département
la directrice régionale adjointe du pôle
emploi réunion et le directeur général
de burger king ont signé une convention
de partenariat visant à soutenir
l'insertion et l'emploi des réunionnais
juste avant l'ouverture de la première
édition des rencontres départementales
pour l'emploi alors l'idée d'aujourd'hui
c'était justement de créer un
partenariat entre le pense et
départementales burger king et pôle
emploi à destination des demandeurs
d'emploi notamment ceux qui sont
bénéficiaires du rsa pour les intégrer
les accompagner dans un emploi qui
aujourd'hui souffrent d'une image peut
être défavorable mais qui offre de
réelles opportunités d'insertion et
d'évolution de carrière
[Musique]
le souhait de la collectivité
départementale est de créer des
passerelles entre les différents
partenaires chômage resté insensible à
ces problématiques
nous sommes en train de travailler un
blanc de précarité et la pauvreté et
dans ce plan qui est très important et
ce volet ciation nous amène à travailler
avec des entreprises quoi proposer aux
réunionnaises et réunionnais aux
bénéficiaires du rsa des possibilités
d'associations dans des entreprises
réunionnaises
cette démarche a permis aux départements
d'engager un renouveau de la solidarité
départementale
une solidarité qui se veut collective
[Musique]